got only watching is a point-and-click
thriller about moral dilemmas and for
decisions in order to survive it's very
focused on storytelling so yeah
basically some sort of dramatic password
and this scenario right here it looks
like it's some sort of survival scenario
can you give us like a little bit of
background and what you have to do to
accomplish your goals yeah and this this
is chapter 4 of the game actually but we
shook us in some different scenarios
here at pax and this one is about to
survive in an alien planet you are
surrounded with your team and you have
to manage the food they're munition the
morale of the team and it's about
surviving until ship comes to rescue you
so the player has to handle all these
things and if you don't let the
situation correctly you it will lead you
to making sacrifices like for example if
you have enough food and the engineer
finish repairing the radio you can
decide to kill him an eight-team in
order to survive mostly the game is
about failing a lot of times and
understanding what it's about for
example the fierce fall is like its own
porn in the don't line up the first
place so you die at the night of
hypothermia so I just spoiled it came
back
yeah you basically have some different
roles in the cam like the soldier goes
to pan the doctor makes medicine for the
team the psychiatric has requires
pitches for the night for Livan up
tomorrow the engineer has to vary by the
radio the robot has information about
Malala steam so so yeah each one is
fundamental piece in the team but when
you have to make sacrifices like who I'm
going to eat survive you have also to
thing which role is less important right
now the situation of the camp and is
there a way to make it through the
scenario with keeping everybody alive
and is that like your goal is or is
there just no way to do and you have to
make those tough choices the full game
you can be the full game without killing
anybody it's like if you have to make
some fights it's because it's because
tool it wrong this to Asian you take the
wrong decisions and to pay for that
mistake you have to make a sacrifice or
face the consequences we want to add a
lot of moral dilemmas in this game but
not just like it's has been done
recently like forcing the player like it
is a spot we'd like to take a decision
like are you going to be good or bad or
are you going to save him or her we just
want to let the prior above himself into
the scene so he can discover himself
like I will justify the sacrifice or it
is unethical it's like we like a lot the
discussion it came from the original
prototype on the internet that somebody
was saying like on the fifth day you
have to kill the dog to harvest refute
and some people like don't you dare to
kill the dog too yeah we like we want to
empower the kind of conversation among
players that's really cool like instead
of having just you know good or bad like
there's so many different objects
actually yeah looks like like
take me through sort of the storyline is
it just a bunch of really interesting
like vignettes and scenarios or is there
like a overarching you know narrative
that you have to kind of play through in
order it's it's a very deep blood in
fact all the saints are like future
plays when you can look up to solve
these dramatic puzzles that take place
in just one shot but each of them there
are six chapters connected by cinematic
sequences it's firm it's them so yeah
it's a pretty big story in [ __ ] that's
awesome that's yeah I think it looks
great it's like a really good take on
the point in click adventure like
anything else you want to say about it
like details or you know when when you
guys plan on releasing this and
everything like that yeah this game is
coming out on Joan this journal and it's
coming out on steamed clam else or and
good old games for pc mac and linux so
yeah by the moment we're just trying to
survive the development of this game
since it's all free its commercial
release yeah we're pretty excited
Oh
Oh
Oh